most bodies have been removed and the
ones that are left have yet to be picked
up
each has to be photographed and
documented
the dead are silent witnesses to what
happened here
and what is alleged to have happened is
russian soldiers attacking civilians
fleeing the city
he went to get some wood when all of a
sudden they started shooting they hit
him a bit above the hill crashing the
bone and he fell down the shooter
shouted don't scream or i will shoot
then they shot off his left leg
completely then they shot him in the
chest and another shot went slightly
below the temple it was a controlled
shot to the head
the mayor of kiev visited butcher to
show solidarity and express anger
is genocide genocide of ukrainian
population
more than sure is that people in russia
and the russian government have to
pay for that painful price officials are
gathering evidence and will submit their
findings that may well form the basis of
a war crimes investigation
i'm a witness because i was here today
we finally have opportunity to register
what happened here
all this will become evidence in our
case
in the outskirts of butcher russian
forces shelled houses
the residents say they were effectively
held hostage
the russians broke into our houses and
took them over they told us not to go
out at night
on the main road leading into butcher
this russian convoy of heavily armored
vehicles lies completely destroyed it
stands testament to the ferocity of the
fight
the town was retaken by ukrainian forces
on the 31st of march
it's only now that what happened here
can be documented
so far the municipality has found 300
bodies but as they search the town that
figure could rise much higher
i've counted at least 10 dead bodies
down this road they're waiting to be
picked up they'll be taken to the morgue
where they'll be recorded and eventually
even picked up perhaps by their loved
ones
although the bodies will be removed from
this road the scars that this town is
feeling will take a lot longer to heal
as will the cleanup
griggery tries to sweep away some of
their debris but it's almost futile
he tries anyway but the scale of
destruction is simply too much
now president vladimir zelinski's also
been speaking he had a message
to francis sarkozy and germany's merkel
he basically said uh ukraine uh wants to
invite merkel and sarkozy to come to
bucha and to see what 14 years of
concessions to russia looks like he's
referencing there the fact that europe
relies on uh gas supplies from russia he
also went on to say that he wants to
wants russia's leaders to see what their
orders have done in ukraine so lots of
very strong language lots of very
emotive terms coming out there from
president vladimir zelinsky and as we
see more and more atrocities more and
more
of the effects of war coming to light
over the next coming days expect that
language to get stronger